and welcome to punch-drunk sportswear
winners win yeah wow what a wonderful
day it's been a crazy week i'm
punch-drunk up just a wonderful time
what happened Duke lost we're all kind
of devastated right Duke's lost the
bracket Buster couldn't be happier
is it really a bracket Buster because
everybody you know it's saying it
doesn't matter if everybody has a Duke
then everyone's on the same page and
it's like the eighth it's like the sweet
what do they call the eighth not elite
ideally eight it's silly eight that's
pretty deep that's pretty [ __ ] deep I
mean they dodged to but I mean everyone
by to sweet 16 and 32 hey man that's how
it goes I mean this is this is Coach Cal
I mean Coach K it's just like at the end
of the game wise and Zion got the ball
am i right ding get a shot up the last
minute 40 why aren't you giving him the
ball force-feeding cuz he made a deal
with the devil with rj Barrett he said
hey man you're gonna be the center of
the offense and late-game situations and
it's sunk them there's all their three
losses RJ Barrett finished the game
taking all the shots and they and they
lost those losses here that Cavs that's
what you're gonna get if you draft him
huh he's good though
I think he's good 232 I dude I think
there's a lot of talent in this league
coming into the NBA this year in this
draft got that kid from Purdue I know
he's 511 but that kid can score don't we
[ __ ] dude that game was crazy dude gonna
be like JD centers at 74 they have a set
of this good good pretty amazing yeah
yeah I mean he they were done they lost
like Virginia was out oh yeah it's like
God it's over good run like P I'm
guarantee you a lot of people switched
over to a different Channel yeah for
sure
and I mean Tennessee going that was some
shady [ __ ] - towards the end I mean it's
just I loved six seconds left you're up
by three and you intentionally foul so
they're shooting two free throws he
[ __ ] makes the first one right
intentionally made potentially misses
the second
and they [ __ ] knock that rebound all
the way back center court yeah and they
still [ __ ] get a shot off and tie
that game that pass was what made it
that Purdue just had to be like what the
[ __ ] just happened to us that's the odds
of you winning with six seconds left you
know and they're shooting freaking yeah
that's why you watch it while you watch
the tournament [ __ ] like this always
happens in that tournament I mean
there's so much talented I like taco
fault
- I think I did you I like NBA but light
bulbs can be interesting dude he's super
thin super - the average 28 he's ugly
dude yeah he is ugly but someone will
hole up Bo ball some chick will be like
you know an arse but that money ain't
ugly bol is his first name and then it's
also his last name
his dad Minuten ball was an NBA for a
long time and he's like seven foot six
or something I don't know I don't know I
don't know you know if you are coming
from the chick who gave her kid a man
take it easy Candice Candice yeah
everyone likes names know everybody
who's everybody
everyone the kids yeah I wouldn't use a
comedy store for any kind of that's good
that's a [ __ ] good point you know as
review wanna talk drug addictions and
STDs that's what you bring up the Comedy
Store okay baby names and baby names and
I was holding my friend's daughter Larry
and that's a really beautiful girl 909
member Sam exactly you guys are all
going to the same weird orgies that
nobody's inviting me - yeah everybody's
just having knock up [ __ ] fast 2018 I
didn't even get [ __ ] invited 2018 the
year of
in people yeah nobody pulls out anymore
I mean it's just too inconvenient
there's Janice Lobo yeah what a handsome
gentleman yeah ball-ball films gonna be
like I think he's cute
yeah you think that bank accounts he's
like seven foot four it's like Tracy
Chapman well his name isn't it it's
names are first name's Diane so I think
there's a pattern here he could punch as
long as he doesn't try to get in the
lane he'll be fine
once you go to Lane he's gonna get hit
dude he's a guy you you know what you
know these radicals want to do in bead
which is the dumbest thing ever were
there like at some place they have them
post out to3 and it's like why are
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
in my life that should get you fired
just for doing that but that's what they
should do for him
just everybody liked him like these guys
who are like long and lanky watch Kevin
Durant watch how he plays he doesn't go
down long bang yeah and he's a different
Jesus special case special ed G's 611
and be able to have the handles of
someone that's six four
you know dude if you greet freak it's a
three-pointer it's all over don't even
shoot shooting threes yeah well I mean
it's unbelievable um we're gonna be
Jason I'll be at the Comedy Store Friday
night if you wanna come and see me in
the belly room hey come on by and that's
about it that's about it worth promoting
that's about it I love it I love it Oh
are we doing the 13th yes I just
realized I'm out of town I would like to
do it yeah there's the wind probability
with so yes chef seconds left Purdue was
91% to well again so I'll be yeah yeah
so the 13th we're doing at the dojo
we're doing the big UFC will do the show
afterwards just like we did last time so
come by and make those flown by and uh
to the watch party and from the dirty
sports you know I'll be there
I just I mean I'm in Alabama yeah oh
yeah get out of there
I can't wait and you doing your flying
saucer - you ain't the Flying Saucer -
come on that's a great name that would
be the know that's what Hicks he named
it or that oh okay now you're hacking
now you're hacking that's why I said it
it so it was an illusion this week I am
at I am at rooster T feathers in
Sunnydale California
what sunnyvale whatever whatever people
Sunnydale do whatever I pronounce that
how I like to pronounce it okay it's the
way I wanna do it okay if [ __ ] car DB
can do a car or whatever word is she's
trying I can say however I want to
[ __ ] say it alright so be in
Sunnydale so yeah I'll be in Sunnyvale
Kerr wants to talk like dude how long
working with me
I can't I don't know the rules of
grammar I just throw commas when my hand
starts to cramp okay I don't know
[ __ ] anything dude so I'm gonna be
whatever city rooster D feathers in I'm
gonna be there Thursday night is our
pimping in the parking lot party
sponsored by natural cannabis company
that's right come we're gonna have a
party and afterwards we're gonna
everybody's gonna smoke weed and I'm
gonna stare at you guys and laugh in the
parking lot so come out for that then
Friday Saturday is straight fire stand
up and then the sunday show is the
mother of all truth bombs stand up in
Q&A so come down if you want to ask
questions that's the show to come down
and do it and bring in church I'm
bringing my silver and black Ronan
shirts and for you people who are 49ers
fans I'm also going to have my Sam Zilla
shirts out there so that's what's going
on and then what else okay then next
week it should be if it goes according
to plan I have two shows at the economy
store at the eight o'clock show is the
tinfoil hat comedy night okay and that's
gonna be with Eddie Bravo myself and
Alex Jones yes and then the second show
is comedy chaos with our good friend
Jill Rogan so it should be a night of
fun and craziness and I'm very excited
about it and then the [ __ ] and then
after that I am at the Nashville Comedy
Festival I'm going to be that that is on
the 13th I
Matt yep it's myself in foil hat comedy
show Eddie Bravo myself
that's a nashville Zanies on that Friday
and then Saturday we're in Huntsville
Alabama at The Improv that's where
you're gonna die yep that's where I'm
gonna die hey is that you're gonna be
with you in Huntsville yes you guys
gonna go do some NASA [ __ ] I'm gonna do
some NASA NASA what NASA's in Huntsville
yeah all right then we're gonna do some
answer [ __ ] what's good tell I'm upset
with both and go I'm gonna do what that
guy does where I'll prove me wrong or
yeah change it to change my mind yeah I
changed my mind space doesn't exist
change my mind I'm going to set that up
right outside
I swear Space Camp is what I'm saying Oh
didn't you go to that and you didn't
show up for a week I went to the one
yeah I went to the one and Jesse didn't
[ __ ] for a week does it I don't know why
that's so hard to believe
did you were you trying no I didn't know
he's obviously jealous what winning
Space Camp you are in like I Oh won a
scholarship to Space Camp first of all
oh wow well I just wanted to make make
clear my parents weren't sending me that
they say that's like my brother's
bragging about getting him no it's not
gonna it's not bragging I got Amelia you
see no I was bragging that my parents
didn't pay it wasn't like you know rich
oil kid okay genius kid okay all right I
I'm very much regretting not having chat
on the show sure thing Johnny Huffman
what yeah what's hard to believe about
that what that you didn't [ __ ]
correlation every night some guy would
take a [ __ ] on the floor of the [ __ ]
dormitorium bathroom and it grossed me
out so I didn't want to go in there and
take a dump in this disgusting filthy
place you could go elsewhere
are you sure it wasn't used sleep
[ __ ] I didn't eat oh yeah I think
the one who sleeps like a nine percent
population suffers from sleep [ __ ]
[ __ ] in their sleep and people that and
they don't realize it and I guarantee
you her beautiful daughter Rick does
that isn't
babies do the real the real conspiracy
is that that's actually what happens
with blackface back in the day they were
sleep [ __ ] and they had they didn't
want to explain it so they just said it
was blackface it actually wasn't you
know what your stories are so crazy
sometimes it like that could be a real
story is this a real story it is not I
already put his own [ __ ] on his face on
this show bones oh yeah remember that oh
I'll never forget it it was so [ __ ]
the US Space and Rocket Center I thought
you're looking up do they not have
toilets tranquility base Huntsville
Alabama cuz you sayin that's where his
face camp was that's where Sam's gonna
die remember well because you I remember
you tell me you went to this now you
didn't [ __ ] for a week [ __ ]
absolutely shocking those seven days
seven days but not like a long weekend
right seven days this would be a
religious a Jewish religious holiday if
this hadn't happened you know and you
when you got home from Space Camp
and the bus like I just picked like a
school bus door opens and he's [ __ ]
just written like kids to grow up and
you're like his mom they're like hi
honey how was my skill wow and you're
just in the bathroom for like four
straight days and just [ __ ] oh yeah I
don't know how you did that dude like it
looked like the Game of Thrones throne I
trained for
you know many months and then you
trained my teammates boy weren't you
like dying by the by day seven I don't
think so must have been farting all the
time not lose weight Yoda did this with
Luke Skywalker for a week was truly
understand the [ __ ] force was NASA
impressed with you like we could send
this kid in outer space he doesn't even
have to [ __ ] you should have put that
into heaven put that in your space file
my counselor was way
oh oh you thought be a good idea not to
[ __ ] around her where people were people
were what was it like normal summer came
for people space [ __ ] and I'm like no
no I it was like third grade playing
spin the laser and I didn't even get
that you get to fly the space shuttle
simulator you know and I got I think I
was in a science station I didn't meet
the pilot it sucked
yeah cuz her word you're gonna [ __ ] your
pants stop farting look get this guy
close enough that we could eject them
how do we know Ari's number please say
it on the three three two three five
eight one two one two nine five zero I
don't know whose number that is but I
apologize to whoever it's number I just
imagine imagine because of his skills
they send Johnny to space yeah and then
when he gets to the space station
someone has [ __ ] this is great I hope
this happens here great what this song
it haunts my nightmares I love it you
came it's going nuts why would they
almost favorite yeah but in yeah but you
did but you also I hadn't [ __ ] for a
week dude these are these are our
Bluetooth earphones scare me dude I got
the boys and I instantly started getting
headaches yeah whatever you say boys
here we go again wow that's like making
fun of a special ed kid for being
special okay I got problems man I'm not
a weird one boys no it's not that weird
it is up there does it really sound like
things I butcher knows the worst no no
doubt for butchering it it's funny
because we don't sometimes you'll say
things that are so out of the realm we
don't really know what you mean and then
when we figure out what you made me like
oh okay
like huazi you used to call waze waze ii
all the time and you're like I'm looking
at huazi and I'm like what is it happy
in a sushi restaurant what the hell's
huazi oh come on get off my back I just
don't know what Y Z is some sort of
shoosh yeah
to be fair the app names are kind of
hard like that the boxing app you know
Daz
I don't even know how how do you know it
is supposed to be it's supposed to be
does own it's what it's supposed to be
that stupid [ __ ] dumb yeah that's
dumbest [ __ ] da is en why don't you just
throw a yawn at the end
why don't you spell something out yeah
what are we pressed for time dumb we
can't even add on four letters to the if
you want it to be called des own call it
does own yeah well I know why it would
be does own yeah they makes that's just
bad I mean your bust my ass for bad
english does own yeah whoever did that
is in their ass yeah your flashlights on
why that's the battery the battery
killer you're welcome
it took me forever to figure out how to
turn that off it pissed me off so much
to turn the flower in like when you
first got it my first guy oh really
who's on forever and it's cold no it's
like I turn my phone off I just have you
got a researcher that's hilarious
alright everybody that has a Tesla says
it's the best thing they've ever had in
their life
including I just read this article Jay
Leno oh say and that's got that's a guy
has what 10,000 cars and he's like this
is the greatest car I've ever had he's
like this is just gonna be the future
yeah red bands have you seen his it's
real cool
he went to most ribbons like I was
thinking you know should I should I get
a house or get a car I'm Mike of course
you picked the car over the house it's
cool yeah what yeah it is cool but I'd
rather have a house yeah yeah I guess I
mean with houses come problems I guess
yeah you know like the value keeps going
up and up and up and up and up and up
but maybe any car value goes down down
down down
yeah I mean he's making so much money
now kill Tony's like killing it it's
he's killing it I'm so happy for those
guys so it's like he's gonna be able to
buy a house but his schools it his car
looks cool yeah I have happy birthday to
Luis Gomez everybody who's Gomez Jorge
how we're talking about good fight
Luis Gomez versus Jorge Perez would be a
great fight oh well my money will be on
Perez in that Jorge prize yeah
I don't know man loose Gomez is good he
looks I mean I'm nothing to him but I
mean he's also never been in prison and
[ __ ] huh
you know didn't grow up in like [ __ ]
South Central I know man Puerto Ricans
are kind of crazy right he was also fine
that guy he was legally blind
to be fair I mean we found out after
that you know he wasn't wearing his
glasses and he can't see it was a good
fight was a good fight
fun they shouldn't change rules my one
guys mounting me up that was ridiculous
that's that's the only thing I would I
would say that would they shouldn't do
they should have to stand there can you
imagine if they haven't in like a real
fight yeah oh no we're gonna allow
kicking now you know yeah imagine that
it's almost like what they do it Duke
basketball where they let him just
completely get away with [ __ ] how funny
was it that they couldn't stop the game
at the end because I didn't have enough
mouse because they had only committed
3,000 entire [ __ ] second half it's
amazing yeah that's why that's a big
reason they lost because they couldn't
put him on the line with eight seconds
left
and can we say a quick farewell to and
rest in peace to traveling I haven't
seen I mean now I can just put roller
skates on hey even I would seem
traveling called the entire tournament
I'm sorry a lot of traveling yeah but
apparently that call is gone so rest in
peace traveling yeah fun while it lasted
it lasted oh yeah I mean like it's your
skin I love the game I love the shooting
I know people like oh it's ruining game
these guys are so good now there's
eventually gonna go back to you're gonna
get a guy it's gonna dominate down low
and then it will be all things yeah all
sports like that is just the evolution
of the sport there'll be something
somebody can figure out and then
everybody starts training for that and
then you figure it out in something
Newcomb's you know last night I was
thinking about Gomez because you were
talking mock kill attorney and he was on
kill Tony last 90s to an Rogan's
Podcast today so a lot of his fans are
there which you know overlap up you know
this show it's a lot of people kept
coming up to me and saying hi and taking
pictures and one guy goes oh man are you
really teed okay yeah I guess man your
voice sounds just like you I go to get
my voice bro and he goes he goes hey can
I just do one question here's what he
wanted to know did you really have sex
with fight nany that's what you want to
add that's the only thing that you don't
believe about our show well I do we
dated for years yeah so you did it this
morning we have a beautiful daughter
named Dave I was like that's the
weirdest question to ask and breaking
news punch drunk breaking news ran into
James to Rio last night oh he was at the
store and what do you have to say he was
kind of quick in and out he was there
watching kill Tony or whatever down here
with his girlfriend I think he's still
in town I think he might go there
tonight or something I've tried to reach
out to talk to him he just hasn't
answered I haven't talked to him in
years I mean every now and then I'll see
him post on the dinner talk to him you
know he doesn't want to talk I was
literally leaving but came over and said
hi you attacked me or you got storm-like
um sitting out front came over
introduced his girlfriend then he had to
leave but people are just we I mean like
it's no the weird one no no's weirdos
running to him how many people just like
don't want to talk like I never liked me
what do you mean don't want to talk yeah
I mean I get by yeah you like you know
he was I mean he would send me like
before I'd even met the guy he would
send me these long-ass emails about I'm
just really shitty email did did you
ever send you an email confessing to
[ __ ] on the bathroom floor so you
couldn't [ __ ] ah more breaking news this
breaking news brought to you by seeking
seeking for all of your ticketing needs
we're gonna be starting to do a lot of
fun stuff we've decide next year we're
gonna go to the McDonald's all-american
game so we'll get tickets on Sikhi where
is that that's in Chicago oh cool we
should all go
baseball starting crazy Dodgers are
already doing this [ __ ] stupid and a
lick [ __ ] so it's good to know rail the
gate there's pink Christie's what pink
oh you know we got a call Steve and tell
me he's the KO punch oh yeah it was like
written so big with like marker really
see Rena ZZ loves the musician pink yeah
I like her but like her life says do you
have all of her songs he can sing every
one of her songs right now without even
it playing the music to it that's
different then yeah see she was cool
yeah the chillers last night by the way
if you could if Davis get they're gonna
be in town go to see key you can get
tickets to that because I saw them on
lentil or Kimmel last night Kimmel's in
Vegas they're from Vegas the killers
they killed it last night the kills
kills killers kill I see you're alive oh
really they're great
but I was totally impressed with that
[ __ ] performance last night so go to
see geek use the promo code punch-drunk
and you will get $10 off your first
purchase man yep get the app have the
app info in your phone
I'll take it to guaranteed you're not
gonna get my man go watch some go to go
to I mean dude go to a baseball game
what am i famil for and go to go to the
Final Four where's the Final Four this
year go watch the clip Minneapolis oh
that's right Minneapolis yeah I mean do
it dude do I mean like I love I love
going to see live bands I love seeing
Rolling Stones only $300 I don't know I
don't know if I want to see them in the
Rose Bowl I went to their first uh final
tour which was over almost 30 years ago
yeah sounds about right
you know I'm saying yes so this be good
that looks I can't be some I love album
do you [ __ ] to this when you put that
that's a real ring when you masturbate
in your windows to watching your
neighbors do laundry I know I don't know
where you got that from you said all of
them are hot yeah in your creepy and
then you put together that I exactly
joining us ah you know a lot of people
call this guy he's got the finger on the
pulse of Jew culture
please welcome Ari Shaffir Trisha
hi buddy hi that's true hi hi guys how's
everybody yeah great re how are you I'm
great I mean [ __ ] winters breaking in
New York you can feel in the air it's
not gone by the titties out what tidal
titties out what are the titties out yet
no no no yeah it was brilliant not fully
here but winter is over I'll be wearing
jacket but the season every day yeah but
when those cities come out I'll be there
reason of smooth fat Hey Dude la's been
great the last couple days man beautiful
tits are out
it's great the tits are ow
the tips are like Mike you're a mom now
okay my tits actually really nice and
they're gonna leave eventually even I do
very I wouldn't pull her off pluck and
put her back no you really do have to
time it and you know like oh I fed her
on my right boob last night yeah a lot
of people do that they all do and you
just have like one one giant it yeah you
out you're like a cyclops Ted that's
[ __ ] great the way to make your tits
not Ari I what's up with the Yankees
have you gone to any games yet no not
yet
what's up there - and - who gives a [ __ ]
[ __ ] 103 games and everybody's and do
hearts out for this okay I think and
Dumars done dude forever not even eat
surgery but he's not be done be done for
the year if he's to be yeah that's what
they said yeah yes well that's a big
loss for sure
no big loss for sure but we have to low
it's key so it's like we can replace
them when the CD comes back but it's
definitely to be a [ __ ]
between their baby will get colin
kaepernick to play short yeah I love
that dude that'd be great he just takes
a knee the whole time Kyle Murray
unless it's hit rate to him he can't do
anything yeah Kyle Meyer dude you know
Colin Kaepernick goes better than most
comedians what most comedians want to
make a statement they stop their comedy
and then in the middle there stand up
they say whatever they have to say
whereas that'd be the equivalent of
Colin Kaepernick on third down on second
down just like hey guys hut hut hike
listen before this play continue there's
one everybody knows police brutality and
we're just gonna take a loss of down on
this one yeah I think before the game
the comic got before the game starts
yeah I totally agree with you are they
problem I mean comics would if they
played the national anthem before every
set why what a nightmare that would lady
why do they play the national anthem at
sporting events it's so dumb oh you know
what it's so dumb so dumb yeah but they
always did I don't know why they do it
they don't they did like 30 years ago
yeah it's just to get people like to
join the military because nobody's
learned they do god Bless America now
and a lot of a lot of games in the
middle game I say no it's not 11 I
should plan 11 I say we go like 10
[ __ ] songs even like here comes Peter
Cottontail that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah they
play ball couple Christmas Johnny be
good I'd like to see Johnny be good
happy birthday to you just in case
anybody in the stands it's their
birthday I really like that baseball
games all right so [ __ ] long and just
whatever you do no sublime please dude
you went too [ __ ] far get the [ __ ]
out of my studio Darren by the way
Aaron's start I just saw her and start
beating off the minute we started
talking baseball yeah dude oh yeah yeah
do
speaking of songs out of cards appear
two and three the brewers beat us up no
I mean how are they gonna be I think
we're gonna beat it there I think
anybody they're gonna be great
Goldschmidt is oh love them hmm go
straight it's great huh what a nice Jew
what a nice joke yeah yeah yeah dude
finally baseball the number one Jew
sport not like these guys are no one's
use for but but we're most Jewish people
our problem it's probably soccer right
no
probably banking right is it banking No
thank you not a support it's a way of
life what is the number one sport that
most Jewish people that have the most
amount of Jew pros follow it's it's all
right well tennis tennis could be yeah I
thought it'd make are they letting no no
what about it off it's soccer I think
it's called being a sports agent it's
actually the number one sport out to
point number one
would you agree this finding didn't
number one female sport is pornography
right that's the number one female sport
am i right am i right everybody you got
you you're the voice of the females on
this show that's saying women aren't
good at anything but having sex
no no sandwich-making is that a sport no
no it should be we're gonna start it up
here yeah we're good all the juice
soccer players oh my god you guys love
soccer race please you gotta race your
way back into the kitchen you [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] Yeah right what they are
vacuuming I love that see it's my
favorite today that was my thought it
was like Jeff can you play with Mac so I
can vacuum I love the you know yeah yeah
you got a couple solo albums this one's
called help this next song is called my
safety word is more he's not here today
buddy
how come he's not there today well we
got called in the principal's office
again I mean dude I'm Jeff [ __ ] what
Kent I don't know what the [ __ ] to do
wait he told not to come in I said take
a week off I thought I took a last week
off no no that's less is a whole - yeah
yeah
the middle of a shell listen I like to
say this so don't interrupt me for about
two minutes okay start the clock
you know as a as a board member of
name-drop we meant off telling him not
to come in his studio we do not we do
not tell comedians what to do anything
that doesn't infringe on the rights of
someone else is allowable whether or not
we find what they say abhorrent funny
unique hacky none of that is alright to
say anything and on behalf of all things
comedy I would like to apologize the
punch-drunk and the Chad do mock for
telling you guys what to do on your
podcast no one should say that but the
members of punch-drunk themselves so I
am sorry that is not we stand for and we
did the wrong thing um yeah I mean like
yeah I agree with you completely I
accept your apology we're I'm in a
horrible spot so I don't know what to do
we accept your apology I don't know man
you should talk to Dave Anthony he seems
to be the one who was really help and
can we be compensated in any way
financially thank you
Dodgers aboard my residue there's no way
competition is gonna happen about sex
actually morals on that yeah you did
admit but I would like say the day right
there anyone else who wants to say this
anyone shouldn't be able to perform our
feelings on a joke or on a technique are
irrelevant to whether or not someone
should be allowed to do them all right
can we relevant can we whether you find
scrolling funny
only too far as long as those infringe
on the rights of another person we will
protect that that's our goal to protect
the ability to do whatever you want
funny or not happy or not [ __ ] unique
or an I agree interesting right stance
wrong pants pro-trump anti chomp none of
that matters the only thing that matters
is we give performers the rights that
perform however they want can we sue
your mom if you are it doesn't matter to
us can we sue you re you can try but you
know my dad is
hahahaha I imagine some powerful Jew is
your dad a powerful you are yeah yeah
now I middle the road but you know no
one else note that but in the middle of
the road powered you is like normal yeah
if you had a mill the road power to
that's like the most powerful Armenian
yep we're like we're $0.99 you that's
like the king of Armenia that's yeah
right take the other way like a normal
Armenian eyebrow is like a standard area
rug for anyone else okay
alright I've got way too far I'm gonna
say one hell of a mustache yeah for sure
I mean area rug yeah for sure for sure
re where are you where are you like
sexually I'm sitting in New York
watching this playground but outside the
East Side community school but I just
saw a janitor take the trash candidate
to take out to the street and instead
taking it down the steps you just put it
on the steps and then through quits then
just let it slide all the way down all
the trash fly out wow that sounds lazy
yeah yeah army that's what I just saw
hey man this guy's taking laziness to a
new level
I'm gonna be honest with you I don't
know how I feel about you just sitting
outside of a playground watching oh I
bet I'm better parents I'm moving into a
new place I'm moving into a new place so
it did over look at this playground so I
was trying to see how loud the
playground is what time they store it
they start recess you know to see if
it's gonna bother me and I would look at
this playground you see all teachers
staring okay I mic my Taft inside my
shirts was like something they were all
like [ __ ] is a school shooter and I
didn't want to dissuade them tithi yeah
keep them on their toes man you always
want to know you always want them to
think is today the day that that creepy
looking guy comes and does weird [ __ ] to
all of us
yeah I already keep them guessing bro
are you them give out the name of that
school so they can be warned please hey
dude they should have East Side
community god damn it
joking es CH s org do you think they'll
ever have you in I like on like a
occupation day like meet the amazing
racist
find out what he does and how he does in
how he turn it into a lucrative career
that'd be fun right I mean John my
friend my friend teachers at a Jewish at
a religious Jewish school and I heard
his kids talking and they were like they
said something like um I'm trying to pay
you mr. Jefferson something like that he
goes what do you say and they were like
nothing mr. mark you wouldn't understand
and he goes no no I think I would what
did you say I'm making this video does
what video like this thing called
amazing race's and he goes that's my
friend like no it's not mr. mark and uh
and he goes yes I want to use Shiva with
him seminary it Israel they're like no
you did and it goes come up kids my ears
in my phone and there's a picture of us
together and these are you know fourth
or fifth graders of the amazing races
that's their [ __ ] Wow right is the
harshness of the internet corrupting me
you corrupting me I really do
they acted like oh you do another trash
can out this guy's [ __ ] great you
haven't speak at our school and he goes
oh I'd be fired no re do they know it's
not real do most people who come across
it know it's not real you think my kids
know kids oh for sure kids don't it's
happening anyway hey they did it go
throw that trash gettin brother what is
I think we got our new Olympic sport
trashcan throwing yeah that's great it's
great audio when you just walk right
into a wind tunnel it's [ __ ] great
the winter off there's problem I'm gonna
go over there maybe patch the audio on
this [ __ ] garbage talk you should
interview Who am I welcome to meltdowns
with Ari Shaffir
we don't so new straight up melting down
hi sir why are you throwing those trash
cans out what [ __ ] you think I am
I got and it's so funny that Johnny and
Ari have the complete opposite [ __ ]
they're like the yin and yang of
butthole one just leak [ __ ] and the
other one's a [ __ ] steel bear trap
Johnny didn't [ __ ] for a week by choice
in third grade but yeah that's true at
Space Camp
that's because somebody put kept putting
spaceman somebody kept putting space
poop in the [ __ ] bathroom the
bathroom as Space Camp was disgusting a
guy would [ __ ] all over the floor and I
didn't want to [ __ ] for a week so I
didn't but did anybody
I can't imagine Ari [ __ ] in the
z-row grab oh my god what happens
there's a sincere gravity I mean you're
just I mean just leaks up illegal
doesn't drip down leaks up just sprays
everywhere I mean dude give us up day on
your [ __ ]
will it ever be normal normal there's
they just blown out for the rest of your
life or at least like half power
normally no it goes up and down it's
kinda like the Hulk where the most
moments use parties Bruce Banner
you don't like me we'll have some some
moments yeah you won't like me what it
had spicy food
all right you when you're having when
you're when you meet somebody new do you
kind of try to hide that until later in
the relationship your ass oh yeah oh
yeah yeah that's not a selling point huh
where would your bleeding [ __ ] come
in to kind of affect the relationship do
you see like like when you guys have sex
is everything look like a murder scene
um yeah I mean I pair it up you know
yeah yeah you kill those guts I know
that I know that the only car do I get
our Ari is it hard to power [ __ ] with
those balls it would seem like you get
it would be so hard to get up and get
that that kind of air action you need to
slam it down your balls always laughing
already
wrecking ball yeah dude it's like can
you even get any air in dollars or just
like short rabbit punches that's
hilarious
that was the trash going down a flight
of stairs text it to me text it to me
yeah I'm sure that guy is more cleanup
like then you have to clean all the
trash obviously that's not his area to
clean up he did the [ __ ] to another yeah
you're right
it never takes anything up it's clearly
the worst invention ever does it ever do
anything a lot of noise pollution yeah
those things are the worst cuz it's like
you just blowing [ __ ] around and it's so
loud you know I mean it's always like
when you're taking a nap on Saturday
someone's got to gaudy Oh going for
[ __ ] two hours I mean you can hear
those things from a block away all right
I got a question about you [ __ ] with
that terrible buddy errs have you ever
told like when you're breaking into a
girl and and she's like hey I we can't
have sex because I'm on my period and
you go baby baby
so am I [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you alright
man shooter turned out pretty good huh
that was great yeah the audio wasn't the
best but the night was amazing the
performance is over
I haven't listened to it yet but I'm
dying to it so I might it's in my queue
yeah it's great
I want to compliment your singing at the
end that was know do karaoke it's fine
I'm like it's not fine it's not fine
it's horrible rere closed his podcast by
singing the wind beneath my wings oh
they're really going he really went for
it too why don't you do that every every
shell like you should just sing in every
shell like Barry's soul what's his name
Barry Sobel was it no no no was it oh
yeah I know
my very diamond oh very time over this
goddamn dog [ __ ] in every podcast I'm
just singing a song I think that might
be good so let's let's let's power rank
what do you think has helped your career
more would you say on your podcast your
TV show or the amazing racist or the
movie you did with the ShamWow guy or
what well he helped me do more amazing
races those that I think probably
podcast I think I've never won number
one with a venomous and in this show
number two but I'll even put into
account like with what the Amazing Race
did when I had nothing else going on so
at the time it was like pretty big for
me just to get like compliments and
bigger comments but I can do that saw
those videos there were so funny
come on so fun out of all that anger and
a loss of jobs and stuff I was like no I
made literally millions of people laugh
yeah and that's why we don't help them
what to do what not because a lot of
people like YouTube would ban those
videos of course I'm like okay but
that's just your interpretation of it it
hasn't hurt anybody especially not I
mean you think it would because of the
way it's job but like it hasn't hurt
anybody and so now you've taken away the
ability for someone else to enjoy a
laugh because someone else might be
offended and that's just not I just so
stupid that comedy is they're trying to
make it like it's this like this pure
thing it was started by scumbags or it's
littered with scumbags thank you and the
most scummy of them are the clean comics
who are full of [ __ ] like not all not
all [ __ ] comics ah
not all clean comics are [ __ ] but
most [ __ ] comics were clean I'm just
gonna throw out put that in the record
they tend to talk do you think of all
the people who were like racing in the
comedy industry like real race and they
were all from the [ __ ] all team yeah
the UCB yeah that's my girl
we start making these rules man
blow up in people's faces that's my
opinion what's happening no the guy yeah
no I got here I love it I love it re
where are you gonna be re I'm gonna be
in Toronto this weekend oh we're at the
Danforth I have only seconds left for
the Late Show where you gonna be
where you headed Terrell oh yeah on the
ground I know you said to run on them
out they're gonna see garnet I'm not the
delivery guy fluorides if I were doing
they re it's me garnet
hey if you're gonna be over there in a
Toronto Area I will be walking there and
I've got an air B&B that we could live
in together and I could maybe make a
tuxedo out of your skin I apologize I
apologize about that
you could probably make a nice fanny
pack out of our he's nuts
there's enough talk about that walking
you can make a [ __ ] suitcase out of
that [ __ ] bag there's so like you
just just for days dude I mean it's just
like wow that's a good question because
how long are you dizzy it's like holding
out more hold on don't know we got more
scene in the shining when the elevator
doors open that's what his [ __ ] looks
like you make them wear life jacket when
they [ __ ] it when you guys have sex no
they gotta wear like a a tarp like those
Ian Gallagher like a front row a
Gallagher that's why Jews make women
wear blankets when they have sex with
little holes in them which are the
original glory holes think about that
because they all a big Jew knots dude
and they just jizz for days the old
ghost elephant do you have the odd big
Jew knots is your man have big Jew nuts
no what are you really only has one big
junuh yeah he's his other night he's
like Pro Bowlers where they have one
giant arm and one little t-rex arm yeah
one it yeah yeah yeah oh you're talking
about a boss one ball can get your
[ __ ] for sure look at that
look at them all one ball you everything
about you everything about getting rid
of that average ball that you haven't
just rocking that one big [ __ ]
avocado Duncan did yeah yeah but just
for shits and giggles you know I mean
Duncan did yeah yeah just like
cosmetically your balls are like the
movie twins right
just like exactly right yeah yeah one
big one one [ __ ] genetic [ __ ]
garbage one yeah one's like a little
[ __ ] and the other one keeps going to
the top I might win if if one twin was
on shore singer on the other twin with
Sylvester Stallone no no no nobody
agrees with that I've seen you're not
knob it's one is sorta [ __ ] the other
one is Brad Williams yeah that's what I
agree they made that small yeah it's not
that dude it's not that big you think
it's smaller in a normal ball it's just
my comparison it's like when you get
like a [ __ ] six as a woman hanging
out with a four and you're like wow
she's not gonna eat how about let's look
right now I have a picture of it on my
phone
a to your balls I mean well fighting
Annie are you comfortable with this
conversation
can you give us green light to become
the sexual harassment a war that's
normal ball that's gargantuan Bob ah
dammit how many inches are you wait a
minute cuz you say I mean like you look
like is are you a grower or shower I
mean like dude I'm a grower for sure
right my [ __ ] goes into Turner I'm ready
to fight my dick is 6 inches I've been
man been measuring it since the moment I
had a dick I just was taking why so you
keep measuring it when I get fat I could
lose an inch in at that number you don't
want to lose anything
my dick is also 6 inches wide but like
why
nobody goes wide what do you got a
[ __ ] coke can for a dick like I push
a hundred pictures and someone else like
alright I got 12 strikeouts
so enjoy 100 pitches yeah whatever dude
so I'm trying to how long are you so
you're trying to say his limp dick is
big you want to take it all thinks how
many in yours is bigger your lipstick is
bigger sir couple minutes I come back
and you guys are I think so I saw man is
easy oh that's right cuz you get him she
was facing right towards me while the
audience saw his [ __ ] were you just
like salivating remember that when we
ought when I was plunger [ __ ] arse
[ __ ] in front of everybody from to TV
and TBS like I'll never forget it yeah I
don't know why they didn't tell you that
was happening or why they would bring
them to that that [ __ ] show they
liked it yeah it's like we're gonna do
on reenact gay porn and the [ __ ] mob
convinced us the plunger [ __ ] okay
that's how you get caught up in [ __ ]
that's how that's every first 48 I was
just there a murderer in my life's
ruined you know I'm just there everybody
[ __ ] started chanting and I next day
ain't no it was like I felt like I was
banging Jodie Foster on a pinball
machine I'm just plunger [ __ ] your
ass in front of everybody and so far it
hasn't really hurt my career yeah that's
a great it's too shiny oh the king of
Armenia I am the king of our mode dude I
get all the deals in Glendale
[ __ ] what would you love me
bowling what's out there remember you
love me aboard
no I don't
oh I don't remember that at all
Oh what else is up what else is up loose
Gomez's birthdays today huh yesterday
actually yeah you know I sing you loose
Gomez should fight Jorge Perez who do
you think would win that fight yeah what
are your takes on this we were talking
about this earlier Ari oh I don't win
white America whoa dude whoa whoa okay
dude what do you mean you got to take a
[ __ ] in a second or do you got to go in
a sense I gotta take this phone call
he would talk so he would talk to us
while he was [ __ ] trust me all right
dude well we miss you all and all right
when you back out now like hopefully
never I have no plan Wow Wow okay I mean
don't mind us why do you hate LA so much
all sudden why are you kicking me yep
that's our janitor I don't want to dance
in my memorial at the Comedy Store when
I die I want that in my memorial look at
me just yeah but that's when it's all
wrong that's called friendship can you
put that on ice can you put that on porn
under the gay section just put it out
there dude why not me and Ari our
friendship goes beyond these [ __ ]
constructs they call straight and gay
yeah dude we paid off our bets night
plunger [ __ ] my friend what if you you
guys become like super popular like in
the gay community from that you guys are
start talking I gather all the help I
can get at this point to at this point
maybe the gay mafia it's the only thing
that could put me over bend you over a
what I'll put you over sorry um all
right are you gotta go uh yeah I gotta
go get out here
that call was brought to you by our good
friends at red yes I bet deicide Betty
what yeah I was talking about that
picture Johnny I'd bet the aside for all
your Betty needs go to Betty acai use
the promo code punch 25 and you are
right 25 that's right and then I you
know the they'll match any donation you
make up to I need to pause you make up
to 5
and they'll give you $25 bedding cash
even if you don't put any money and that
is 25 3 bucks to bet on whatever you
want and you could bet on all kinds of
things at our good friends bed dear sigh
everything all the bets are guaranteed
they pay out quick and fair and baseball
you mad I'm buds final four for sure I
take that 25 go do a parlay on the final
4 and then the championship [ __ ] it
free money when you win free lose you
didn't lose anything
yeah I mean like and then the fights
this week we're great I was wrong I
think I'm actually liking the UFC on
ESPN they're just putting out so many
fights now going for it four weeks in a
row I think that's amazing
it's getting like boxing their boxing
every week why can't they have UFC every
week yeah I mean it sucks you got paid
for that plus [ __ ] but really pisses me
off I mean I want to see how how much
these fighters are making they should be
getting a piece of this deal did you do
you know did you guys watch Cooper who
have kissed the yeah what do you think
about this it's so interesting yeah I
mean like does he know her yeah he says
he kind of knows her from like she's
apparently just cheese her off dude look
at that you know he's photo he just won
he's a heavyweight yeah by Anthony
Joshua next I think yeah yeah yeah
what's he's like well I am from I would
fight man for you and then I would hit
you in the head with club and then I'd
make love to you as you are dead it has
been entire a week since I take [ __ ]
there we go here we go come on he's like
I did he's thinking should I do this
should I do this
just kiss Ali Wong and get it over with
she's pressing charges and he's he's
what he's like who is he pressing
charges and she says she says that he
grabbed her ass after that he should sue
her you should sue her yeah goddamn
right she was all up in his face looking
asking for it now you can't fight
California until he explains himself he
has to come to California and explain oh
she looks like every asian porn star got
my dick hard so I wanted to kiss her oh
she went for that one oh yeah what is
that
the number-one one Korea already oh the
worst if you have her just assume that
you are yeah it's just so bad it's just
so bad dude how many Dalmatians you
think she's killed she wants to kill all
the Dalmatians
she's look at that dude she wants a
hundred one of them she got kill all of
them is it not an excuse that hey I've
just been struck in the head multiple
times yeah literally bleeding yeah I
mean we don't know they're real honestly
the way she was standing I thought there
were a couple like talking yeah doing a
video she was so close to him and have I
ever in is good come on things like some
hardship between each other I'm telling
you right literally touching do you have
you guys seen the porzingis [ __ ] about
this he's been accused of rape by a
chick who wanted the Knicks to negotiate
a sixty eight thousand dollar deal but
she still wanted to date him after and
he didn't want date and she said that he
raped her after the day that he just
destroyed his knee or Tour's ACL so he
had a basically a season-ending injury
and then she says he raped her and that
but she still wanted to date him did
that help his knee probably dude
probably you heard it here first
anytime you blow your knee out rape
somebody oh I do not stand backstage but
that's not blow up in our family and
Kiba no that wouldn't be the worst deal
Jim Dylan's mine right yeah okay they
actually told Dallas when Dallas got him
and now still took him which isn't a
good look for Dallas cuz Dallas ah has
their own sexual assault chick going on
right now
butts just like here we are man I'm
telling you this is this is shady as
[ __ ] it's a shady deal which time which
one is the purging as well yeah it's
just like ours
he raped you now you wanna date but you
still want the date I mean I mean if
you're gonna a lot of these athletes
more than any other celebrity or what
everyone say are [ __ ] around with the
wrong kind of dingbats here's the
problem is that crazy chicks are the
best in bed
I mean here's the problem well because
you're pretty fun to [ __ ] what dead
chicks dude they'll do whatever you want
man you got like two hours before they
get too cold and then it's like weird
that scares me that scares you hear me
that Jack you think there's a real like
undercurrent in the Society of necro
necrophilia right ah I'm not know wasn't
that okay what's that weird-looking did
you see I was just here me do a show on
[ __ ] necrophilia know them a lot on
pedophilia which is incredibly bad which
is cracking me up about this Joe Biden
[ __ ] how everybody's like all everyone's
like this is weaponizing the movement
yeah we've been saying that forever here
are these photos that Ari yeah those are
some Chuck told [ __ ] these it's like
a pile of trash it's not even bad like I
thought trash should be everywhere today
obviously has a system up and it seems
to be working right he's got pick up
that bag push it back in but for the
most part doesn't hurt his back you must
send it down wheels first well you know
hey I'll come down there wheels first
people who have jobs that where they
have to do the same thing every day they
you know you get into a system and you
yeah
that's why in restaurants they like to
fire you after two years that's our
motto because you start cutting
yeah Penn corners you start cutting
corners so if you're there for five
years you've really outlasted what they
watch they they want turn and burn
everybody turn and burn yeah if you go
in a restaurant a bunch of old ass
waiters you know it's a bad place oh
well you know dude like some of those
places where you can make like career
money like those restaurants that are
like so high-end those old steak joints
yeah yeah those guys are there for like
30 years
yeah when they have the whole system
down and they don't ever leave it I know
somebody that works at masters in
Beverly Hills just makes Bank like can't
quit that job for a career job because
you're like I'm taking a pay cut to
[ __ ] you mean go be some [ __ ]
lawyer or whatever the [ __ ] like I'm
making more money good money why quit
yeah I mean every tabs [ __ ] 18
hundred bucks yeah you know I mean if
they tip you're good to go
yeah a lot of times they just include
the
yeah they should I mean that's $350 a
table a table night table yeah yeah and
a lot of those ballers are just like
damn here you know his four grand you
know the best tippers are strippers they
really have new people that we know well
yeah that's true they're bad with money
but you know who's good tippers people
that work in a service industry
yeah like bartenders tip good waitresses
and waiters tip good because they know
that's how it goes you knows bad tippers
anybody from another country yeah
because they they get paid more
our Lee yeah they don't know that
they're supposed to tip yeah it's just
like if you was my favorite part going
Canada is not tipping anybody so I'm
like yeah payback [ __ ] you don't tip I
mean you're not opposed to yeah you're
not supposed on't pay that's what I mean
they don't tell listen dude you know
it's like in in uh in New York I think
that's a right-to-work state and it's
just like I think minimum wages like
three dollars or five dollars it's
ridiculous you know here's the whole
thing I mean like I wanna get into but
it's like the more money employees make
that's the more money they can spend in
the economy that's the whole thing about
this thing was wages go down they're
gonna be able to buy less [ __ ] now they
would NAFTA and that would free trade
now robots how's anybody gonna make a
[ __ ] living I mean watch this baby
they come up everybody have a podcast
everybody everybody already has a
podcast I know it's [ __ ] nuts right
everybody already has a [ __ ] podcast
I don't know what does that even mean
I'm looking at my notes what I'm going
to talk about it makes you know no exam
is that the phone without apps or yep it
is
yeah how's that going what's that
experience been like it's fun you know
I'm really honestly it's helped me with
my addiction to the apps I'm not on them
as much what can you do from this phone
tax call that's a uber internet so you
do have some apps yeah I mean I have
like yeah get around apps and be you
know just you just don't have social
media and tell me honestly
have you ever downloaded Instagram yeah
and then I undid I had to get something
out but then I deleted it yeah you can
go online and do it without getting the
apt okay you got it oh yeah
I thought Instagram is doesn't have a
website yeah it does but I thought you
can't upload yeah I thought so
log in and look at it you can't upload
yeah cuz I can go to it on my laptop
yeah you you can but it's a pain in the
ass you have to do a whole thing yeah
but I don't you might not even be able
to like DM people on the online one you
die I don't think you can upload [ __ ]
you can only touch camera you have to do
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] first but you might
not be even be able to you know when
Instagram went down how many like
[ __ ] Instagram mobs were like oh my
god
all my power is gone yeah yeah I was
down for a short time and so it's
Facebook they're down at the same time
Lana laughs mouths must have been
freaking the [ __ ] out
that's hilarious oh my god hold pictures
in cell phones a protein that's what it
is the selling of stuff that they're
really good they think it was gonna
break forever it wasn't even a day it
was I wonder how many of them are crying
like you see all those videos are like
those like 14 year old kids like it's
always boys and the moms will take
[ __ ] like their video game away or
the dad will come in and just hit the
[ __ ] thing with a bat and just break
his things and they [ __ ] nap I can't
go there hilarious snapped after their
dad shall smash everything with a bat
yes I was in an uber on Sunday but I
mean snap-snap like you know III can
imagine that those Instagram models
doing that and this mother was had
probably like a five year old kid in her
arms and he was slapping the [ __ ] out of
her face dude and she just had this big
smile he was going wow she was like that
why was she smiled she set him down tied
his shoe and patted him on the head and
picked him up again right no wood
chipper smacking it right now right in
the face you smacking her well the
problem is if you did something in
public people would be called and
[ __ ] Child Protective Services it's
like people are getting honest you
should be able to spank your kids I
don't give a [ __ ]
whole dr. Spock [ __ ] about don't not
spanking your kids and all that [ __ ]
whatever [ __ ] him anyways the point is
is that that always a PSYOP to raise
awful children
I did I just I was why why would why why
would they want us to Ray Ray's awful
children now what's the point
ah the Rays awful kids because uh they
just think they go into the world and
they [ __ ] die they have an
unavoidable expectations and then they
get out and they get into the real world
and now everything they're taught isn't
real another on psych meds cuz they're
just they're [ __ ] um they're
depressed they go into therapy right
they go into jobs thinking they're the
boss it just doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make any sense I agree on
that yeah it doesn't make any sense
we are weaponizing idiots I said we
throw kids in trash cans and then push
them down the stairs wheels first
that's punch-drunk you know it I mean
have things better which are the kids
better are they doing better with this
new way of like kids are adults let's
treat him like that dolls let's give
them all warts is it better no I don't
think it is we're just raising crazy
people and they all get on psych meds
eventually because everything they're
told was [ __ ] and they don't know
how to deal with it
so they got a numb [ __ ] out it's all
a long con answer this honestly and
really think about it crunches know
virtually nothing to do with sex how
many in an octagon eight-year-olds could
you fight at once and be to beat all of
them like how many do you think as many
as you could fit a crowbar these kids in
I'd [ __ ] them all yeah okay yeah but
midgets are different
no I fought grown ass [ __ ] their
videos their video that yeah is it on it
has gone all head kicks bro some like
you know you have right now tried you
like you admit it comes into a [ __ ]
I do do one see how high you can get
dude yo she'll rip your spleen
goddamn teeth you're gonna face what is
Mitchell now on his [ __ ] they don't
let you get close enough though I mean
they get if they get like right here you
know I'm saying you can't when they were
running around and you were chasing them
what's up with it playing that Benny
Hill song yeah you kickin [ __ ] I know
we beat up a bunch of midgets yeah
there were midgets in that no he's just
saying they're midgets Oh
midgets she said ending yourself that
wasn't even like a joke I'm gonna be
honest I I'm doing pro wrestling you be
ten ten eight-year-olds no problem no
problem how fun would that be not fun I
would lie but there with the Terrible
Peters soccer mom doesn't go in from a
child they're all on psych meds and
they're all the bad ones the bad kid
yeah yeah yeah population control at
this point
no your week not the dumb-dumb my thing
well it's myself I did some research on
this thing called Oh Montauk Project
have you heard of it okay Montauk yeah
moving right along hey the football
league is folding do you guys see vas
all that well they said it was coming
for the last but they thought they were
gonna be able to finish the year and
they can't even finish the year oh by
the way last week we're the final games
so oh really yeah who won the
championship they didn't never had one
there was one team that I think was 7
and 1/2 but they're like they're not
getting crowned as anything that can't
even afford to buy a goddamn trophy I'm
telling you bro that one's football
seasons it's like throwing a Halloween
party the day after Halloween nobody
wants to do it they it's like here then
move up move on it's like football in
the summer or the spring doesn't make
any sense summer they should do that
base the minor leagues should either be
on Fridays or Sundays or the small
markets minor league is on Saturdays and
it's called the n-c-double-a yeah but
they should they need another league
that's in between that
I mean I know the n-c-double-a is will
do everything they can to not make that
happen well I mean they're already
freaking out about the one done see
Coach K he's like well yeah yeah he was
he was protesting baby yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what are you doing the carbage
trying to get rid of the one and done
well yeah they say they're gonna get rid
of in 2012 which means lense which means
what you have to do at least two years
no they go right to leak which is
hilarious because I got hurt and they're
like we gotta get rid of it but then if
you have next day you know but if you
actually watch Zion in the rest of gay
him playing actually raised his stock
because when he was coming in to he was
fourth yeah but for everybody who's talk
it raises I mean there are people like
camreta she was gonna might my name
being a lottery now we're going to do
can he would they were going one two
three right yeah yeah but that's fine
doll because that's better for him it's
I mean like it's dude because you won't
get that quick pay that's fine they say
you have a real long career I want to
get that quick pay yeah yeah for sure
I want my first paycheck to be as big as
possible
that's what Dania that's dude there's
big checks out there if you go to the
right place they said that his shoe deal
will easily exceed 100 million well did
you see they're trying to they're saying
that busted shoe is worth 250 grand it's
got stolen it was stolen they don't know
where it is that's why that came out
course it got stolen do you think Nike
wants that out but they said it's worth
$250,000 and somebody jacked it and
everybody involved in that play that
play didn't get paid Xion or the people
made the sneaker yep that's right
dude there's an argument Coach K's the
one with the sneaker deal yeah 100
percent the NCAA this is ego okay it's
rate 100 percent no what about Calipari
now a lifetime deal at Kentucky UCLA you
know offered in my [ __ ] like offering
less than he's already making like what
are you an idiot well and I apparently a
big sticking point with UCLA and this
surprised me is that they don't have
charter flights for all their games
almost every major program has charters
a flight for every game and they they
don't do it they so they still fly
commercial and if they're like four
coaches that's really hard that's like a
big deal yeah like there are small
market that's jumping artist
charter flights for some games this year
no they should have charter flights to
anything that makes them money it's
great okay I mean this is the big thing
we've created this [ __ ] environment
in [ __ ] college where everybody's
equal
and like welcome to another thing
another sign up it's not real man
if you don't generate enough money you
can't get paid to the sports that make
money they should get paid it's just the
truth man it's just the truth well I
don't know why basketball should have
chartered plane should have private
planes well here's a way to do it
equitably though let them profit on
their own image that way the most
popular player is getting money and then
you don't have to pay [ __ ] everybody
you know I'm saying like just let them
sell their image to video games and [ __ ]
like that yeah that's ridiculous since
they can't like the MTA tried to put out
a game like where's all the money gone
I'll tell you where it goes
administration costs everybody's making
money off that [ __ ] they the deans the
professor's all their their [ __ ]
money goes up I saw this thing that
wasn't I can look it up because there's
like one of those crafts that was every
state was just a you know map of America
and it was each state's highest paid
state official and every one of them was
a college coach yeah should be not the
governor not to [ __ ] in not [ __ ]
mayor of whatever [ __ ] biggest
metropolis not [ __ ] anybody in the
military that [ __ ] an NCAA coach
well like almost all 50 states yeah for
sure there's a real but maybe Alaska I
think Alaska's was a [ __ ] otter but
other than that Chupacabra yeah so yeah
I mean like it's just stubbornness and
they're gonna kill their thing by not
wanting to pay these guys and the
money's getting ridiculous
well what it's also coming down to I
feel like is that a lot of people a lot
of these athletes and we're seeing it a
lot with a lot of the retire early
retirements and people bouncing is that
now with everybody that understands with
CTE s you have X amount of a window
before you really start doing some
damage to your brain how many of those
years do you want to play for free and
make somebody else money so if I can
ghost if I want to do eight years and
that's it I need to make money for the
rest of my life in those eight years at
least enough to
a couple car dealerships when I'm 35 or
whatever and my old body's gonna be
wrecked I'm gonna be walking with a cane
in my 50s everything yellow and orange
is either a football yellow is a
football coach orange is a basketball
coach green as a hockey coach why is
there one hockey league state
why is hockey big in that State Teachers
close to Canada and then blue is not
yeah so Medical School Dean seems to be
a popular one yeah and they make that
yeah why they make money's cuz they
[ __ ] charge kids so much money to
become Ghana dude how am I suppose you
have to pay that somebody that much to
go to [ __ ] North and South Dakota
that's what it is look where they are
it's only those two states yeah I mean
dude I mean we go all the way look
Nevada it's a medical school plastic
surgeon of course yes dude casinos pay
for half your tit job yep they will pay
you to get big tits and a 65 real guy
pays for the other one yeah all right
not right when we're making political
statements on the show [ __ ] finally
[ __ ] finally yeah I can't believe
that's gonna that Football League's
already done they said they rushed it
and that's their big mistake and that's
why the XFL is going slow with it
they're taking two years well I think
that's I think they tried it because
xml's announced first yeah and then this
thing got announced and I think they try
to like jump the gun and get ahead of
the XFL and also get more pluck get the
players and get all you know why night
they had a good idea this idea of having
guys that were like regional you know
went to schools in that area sure I
think that's that to me that bring their
shows
that's whatever you have see fight is
they're all locals they're just bring
her show but also can you can imagine
kind of want to follow you guys that
maybe didn't make it on your college
dude I think that this biggest mistake
is doing it in the OP in the NFL's
offseason they should be on a Friday in
mid markets that don't have a huge
football Pro the XFL is gonna fail too
don't you think yeah if they do during
the summer
yeah it's why the WNBA doesn't work I
mean you say whatever you want but that
is that's an indoor sport I the W
right but listen man more they can play
more - moon and people's - wouldn't
watch that [ __ ] I mean dude it's a it's
it's a Gordon for turn summer it doesn't
want me women's college basketball is
more exciting than the WNBA to me yeah I
think you're just doing that because
your mom no no I prefer it why I would
rather watch two mice women's tournament
then the end WNBA playoffs oh for sure
yeah
I just love basketball yeah I understand
watch anything man I mean I watched high
school ball when it's on I watch they
gotta lower that rim that's the truth
man they got a lower that big dunk so I
mean just get a little girl I mean like
I would say Irish for everybody
whoo-hoo who put that chick as winning
the dunk contest have you seen that no
like the guy jumped over four people and
she beat him because she jumped over
like a dude sitting she did it she
dunked yeah it's dumb why it's like kids
it's like kids and talent shows they
shouldn't be allowed cripples and kids
should not be an adult an adult town
shells because they have an unfair
advantage yeah yeah oh yeah right it's
like oh dude I'm a great singer but but
I don't cerebral palsy boom you won you
know watch this right here
yeah just here we go so dumb I'm
embarrassed for everybody involved
she got those cream abdul-jabbar got me
it's so darling oh my god yeah it's you
like that's what I heard
I gotta be honest with you what you
didn't really hammer it down either kind
of rim lose a good dunk it's sure
because she won the contest over a guy
who leapt over like 47 people it's a
good dunk but why are you putting her
with the guys it makes no sense and
she's wearing a cape maybe she's a
vampire maybe she can fly what are you
saying she's blade no she's wearing a
cape yeah he's got a sword on her back
what's her nickname Black Panther you
know it's just [ __ ] weird dude yeah I
mean I don't care I just think I
I mean I'm just I don't know I'm just
not a WMA van yeah Wow it's you looking
[ __ ] I do like other people with
anti-women basketball I just don't find
the WNBA as exciting against there's
already an established brand and it's
just like it's just that we've said
before the the sport female sports are
do well are two ones that can piggyback
on male sports tennis golf tennis and
golf great brand new sports like MMA or
X Games you know it's like those girls
do well in those five hundred percent
agree with you the Braves have signed
running all Kunia to a 100 million
dollar extension nobody cares
damn reigning Rookie of the Year little
early so early a little early it's gonna
look a good deal a couple you know
you're like oh yeah that could be a good
good but that's how crazy baseball money
is the records that you get paid it's
just like I go again guaranteed
contracts are gonna kill pro sports so
just gonna kill pro sports I can't hate
on somebody getting money no I'm not
against them getting money it's just
like he's signed through 2028 club
options the last two years but Jesus
dude that Bryce Harper is going to blow
up in their face it's gonna blow up in
their face he is hitting better after
but how bad are Philly fans like I did
put him in like your first game dude I
would have taken away I would have taken
the [ __ ] Nationals offer ten years
three hundred mil versus what 12 years
340 so much less pressure to in DC he's
a high intensity sport why you know
they're crazy crazy yeah why would you
take that I know he wanted the long he
wanted the years man he wanted as many
years as possible to hear what the
Nationals offered him it was like we're
gonna pay this much but it's extended
over till you're like 75 years old
what like Bobby veneers yeah but even
longer it's like he's not guaranteed to
live that long
it's so dumb like if he dies in a car
accident that should go to his money
they should why his family they still
have to pull a win in the lottery
because otherwise they just assassinate
him yeah all right admittedly psycho
funny he starts hitting under 300 [ __ ]
he's got a little red
that is a great question I was wondering
what would happen with that right we
gotta kill this [ __ ] guys guys we're
gonna kill him I gotta kill him what do
you guys think so do you guys know who
that nipsey what's his name
MC hustle yeah I got shut down and how
could he started hitting under 300
that's how you got a conspiracy no but
everyone's going apparently if you put
out a doc now ah you get killed
well the documentary he was gonna put
out was about this guy called dr. C B or
someone yeah who has he's like a
naturopath yeah you kinda it's like
homeopathic man yeah and you know what
vegan diet who else but I documented I
got killed
well I mean that's the whole thing about
Chester Bennington and Chris Cornell
they had one coming out that DJ had one
coming out I think the point is that
everybody who lives in [ __ ] Hollywood
has a documentary coming on I think
that's that's like documentary select a
new podcast yeah there's a new book
you're working on my documentary we are
definitely the new books yeah for sure
did you watch that cocaine cowboy one I
haven't dude I don't my TV time i
cocaine cocaine I didn't cocaine Island
yeah cocaine Island I mean that new
documentary on Netflix
well it's insane if it's so insane why
don't you marry it that makes sense that
makes a lot of sense oh man good times
yeah watch that one it's crazy
I wasn't seen I will watch that I will
watch it
spoiler alert everybody dies at the end
of it but it's [ __ ] good it's so
[ __ ] good you know what's so [ __ ]
good my fantasy basketball team in the
championship hey congratulate xed year
are you in
no I I mean I mean what did you play in
the season yeah I beat the [ __ ] out of
them in the playoffs I mean how many I'm
each player changes did you make a lot
yeah I think I'm yeah yeah yeah I'm
gonna make a new rule wouldn't you get
the playoffs yes no nope nope no trying
can't sign free agent players get hurt
yeah [ __ ] it yeah look we up your [ __ ]
welcome to life Johnny you
are you really comparing it fantasy
basketball to regular they control next
year a new rule you can't take that you
may add anybody I got a new how about
this rule yeah nobody can have anybody
on their team yeah I'm down with that
too
I'm down with that everybody wins yeah
everybody loses yes really happens yeah
fall yes if it's yes so much why don't
you marry it oh snap she got me good at
him did you see that Kim and Walker
status and you the other day yeah he had
the starting lineup had 53 points Kim at
Walker had 47 of the 53 pleased that
bridge is any good
no so he's not doing well not really
Todd with John bridges from Michigan
State he can dunk the ball and that's
about it he can't chew no he can't shoot
he didn't get lost in college yeah a lot
of them doing college mock man he's not
he's a flameout he's another bus we
should have taken Donovan Mitchell not
[ __ ] Malik monk Malik monk can shoot
though Donovan Mitchell's averaged 23
points a game malik monk is a DNP every
night doesn't get in a game damn Johnny
this Malik monk makes Johnny want to
take out a the Hornets I'm telling you
dude it's it's guaranteed contracts they
suck what they suffer mid-market teams
yeah yeah they do it's like dude it's
it's you're just destroying it for the
fans well in the Supermax too is gonna
be like cuz we're gonna if we want to
keep Kimmel we're at the famous Supermax
deal yeah that [ __ ] the franchise and
blows up in your face yeah blow your
[ __ ] face it's guys suck dudes player
empowerment though I mean that's what
this the arrow we're in right where the
players have all the power
well I I do I here's the thing about the
NBA if you're going to make changes you
have to do it now because these guys are
making so much money now they're gonna
be able to strike for a little while and
listen I want them to get paid I have no
problem with them getting paid the
problem is that when you give them these
long contracts if they check out if they
get hurt it destroys the franchise
yeah dude Batum and mkg Nick Batum is
out of shape and this has been terrible
we've got 40 million dollars between
those two where else is that we can't I
mean the part of them there's many
reasons why but to your point part of
the reasons Nick sucks so much is
because what carmella did find out
they couldn't make any moves because
they had so much money to this guy who
was without question underachieving the
last six years dude he's in the old
school he's like he's from that Jordan
era where it's like the player was
bigger than the team yeah you know well
that's half the game now he's trying to
get these shitty contracts traded off
your team it's but it's just like the
NFL like all of these teams that are
that have really been great or have made
great pushes in the last ten years all
have one thing in common a smart [ __ ]
gia and young core not a great coach the
guy who's drafting and the guy who's
getting free agents and the guy who's a
financial wizard all of those teams are
always in the [ __ ] playoff
quarterback Jerry West what player who
became a GM was good it was Larry Bird
Larry Bird okay no Larry Bird turned the
paces around when you GM of the year
that's it okay so yeah those two anybody
else
Isaiah's worse I guess for bill Jackson
was even bad yeah as a GM well the three
dozen Phil Jackson did a great job of
like resetting the Knicks and being like
okay we're not just gonna sign you know
because the Knicks are getting his
Yankees mentality or just sign names but
that's not basketball Larry Bird was the
only person to ever be Finals MVP season
MVP head coach of the year GM of the
year the only person in NBA history to
get all four of those but he's nothing
compared to Jerry Jerry of course Jerry
West is not mount wherever's he's the
mountain I think Jerry Stackhouse is
gonna get the Vanderbilt job either
which I don't know how I feel about that
yeah kind of weird I just I mean does it
ever work when you go right to coaching
not penny penny uh yeah yeah yeah he is
he's recruiting like [ __ ] crazy man
like I'm moving like a suspicious
Alabama right nothing no pennies do
Memphis Memphis right yeah that's where
he played right now yeah yeah okay that
makes sense then that makes sense to me
dude you see a play there UCLA you want
a coach here are the two people I think
you should go after well they're going
after what's-his-face of TCU
first of all they're gone after a
handicapped guy and a woman they went
after Anthony been a real continuous
coach I don't like that I don't like
that I don't I think you CLE needs up
more up-tempo guy and after Calipari I
like I like Rick Barnes and I went to
see Jamie Dixon and I think Jamie Dixon
would be fine but I really think the guy
Texas Tech is who they should go after I
think if that guy can win they're all
about Kellan Sampson at Houston he's I
like him but he's got all that scandal
behind it but I think he'd be great -
what's what about that Calipari zwei f--
yeah what's the Penny Hardaway puppet up
- like maybe he can coach that's a good
one little bit
I'd be a good one Spike Lee Gregg head
coach he be great be wonderful you CL
like they want the the latest thing
about getting chasing kids like he's
flamed out the last two places how does
he keep getting [ __ ] jobs I guess but
everybody you hear that like he's like
he's watts getting the back into the NBA
which I think he means playing which is
gonna happen or get into coaching he
should one hundo I'm gonna call it sure
why not and what about a ghost I would
hire ghosts have all the ghosts are
banging chicks now all these chicks are
like I'm getting [ __ ] I got gangbanged
by go yeah what's up dude you're on
would punch-drunk sports where winners
win what's up damn how are you guys
doing I'm you know what we're really
doing well thank you for asking how are
you I'm excellent Sam you know I wanted
to go out of my way to tell you I wanted
to you thanks for coming to this cold
frigid [ __ ] tundra of Minnesota when
you came here oh thank you don't want to
know Jason Tebow what's it take to get
you here pretty much just a bicycle
again three-quarters of a ham sandwich
waiting if you're interested dude I'm on
the next train I don't know if we got
trained here yet but oh what can we talk
some fights real quick yeah of course
buddy yes we haven't even really gotten
into it too much yet how about this
Justin Goethe man is there a more
exciting fighter in the history of the
game it's an he's pretty exciting and
that guy I can punch now he I think he's
got him in the eye with his finger
though in this last fight could be but
that dude can [ __ ] punch he's scary
he's one of those ones he has scary
power I think he's answered Habib I
really do
I don't know I do his style is like his
style man can it's good it's not that's
the style that doesn't bode well for a
long career he stands in the [ __ ]
bands along for sure yeah he is Rock'em
Sock'em and it's just like at some point
you get clipped it comes to an end you
know yeah kind of like a Liddell kind of
yeah I'm Adele got knocked out one tooth
so fun and too many times
it's called mixed martial arts there I
mean like okay they do some ground and
pound you Jitsu but really is it's just
dirty boxing I mean it really is like
there's no like when you think like
Bruce Lee and martial arts right it's
like blocks blocks blocks this is just
like I can take more damage than you
yeah I can take way more damage than you
and that's really half it half it
where's the Wing Chun [ __ ] who do you
think who do you think they give next to
Justin um that's a great question I
don't know what does it fight anything I
was gonna say I need rankings Johnny
what do you think what do you think who
do you think he not even ranked I know
he's got a no no he obviously went up
after this yeah he wasn't I mean Barbosa
you know he's a great striker but they
put Cerrone ahead of him it looks like
he was pissed about that he had that in
his speech
I think Cerrone I think that'd be good
fight I'd like to see those two fight
that'd be great I mean it seems like
he's pissed off enough about him oh oh
man La Quinta that'd be a good fight
between those two you know I love is he
gay chief Ferguson when Tony yeah I mean
like I hope Tony comes back I know he's
having some mental he's at five yeah you
know I hope he comes back
oh yeah there is okay like a theme fight
I mean I'll be good poor you would be
he'd [ __ ] McGregor up I think who I
don't think I don't think so I think I
like that man I like I like Connor
versus a lot of guys except for kabhi I
mean knock Barboza the [ __ ] out
you know he gave him the old bye fish
Lisa bye fish Lisa nobody under Cerrone
should he fight
no just the tough one maybe Kevin lead
nobody I mean like who's I mean who
doesn't fighting for the Bell i
acquaintance could be a good fight with
her
i like that 70 now who Kevin leaves
going up to 170 oh yeah that's right
still number six the hot inking yeah I
don't want to see him fight Kevin Lee
anyway I'd like Iaquinta or [ __ ] I'd
love to see McGregor fight anybody but
this guy keeps retiring every 20 minutes
every time he doesn't get what he wants
oh dude he's like the guy that has all
the toys in your neighborhood and when
you do not playing with him the way he
wants he bounces or kicks you out
I agree but he claims that now he was
fighting for like the rights of the ESPN
the thing like none of the fighters are
getting paid what they should be with
that he should have joined a union long
time ago
[ __ ] Ronda Rousey should have done it
where she's walking out the door they
need a union dude they need a union you
know who doesn't want him to have one
everybody yeah everybody everybody is
gay
hi Dana doesn't she's like [ __ ] that
phone rings now there's two two
different times I got calls this week
one was magical who's calling me from
London one was Dana and those are two
calls I always answer and when Dana
calls me or I'll calls me someone's in
trouble and usually me or Sam or both of
us Dana calls me some like oh [ __ ] I
gotta go call Dana back she texts me oh
don't worry about calling me back it
wasn't important I just wanted to let
you know that the Dodgers are want to
know like we have this many games
laughing you're already talking the
Atlanta Braves did kick the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of the Cubs yesterday eight to zero
yep six one six air is the most enjoy
one month the sun shining it I just
wanna keep it up I love you all thanks
buddy thanks for calling Thank You bud
you guys watch the one fights Mighty
Mouse no IDL virus that's gotta be
[ __ ] crazy
he actually there you got I know yeah
yeah I told Jeff feels like they just
fight different in Japan
how it was in Pride and stuff but it's
not obviously like that but what was
what was that on it was that do you have
to like buy it or rent it or an app that
I don't have but I saw how did you watch
it online
what was it okay okay I just want to
look out cuz I still actually haven't
seen the highlights of that no I was
curious but I read what happened but I
didn't have to watch it but I saw you
not come out was good - I love Mighty
Mouse I love him - and obviously you
want him to win since he's going there
to like make a statement leaving the UFC
yeah I wish he didn't leave the u.s.
he's I think she does that on purpose
I've said before they release people
that don't necessarily hurt their bottom
line but I have enough name recognition
so it seems like a big deal like you
know everybody they release is like you
know I mean they they're like number
three number four number five they're
not the main guys that sell a lot he was
the main guy though no he wasn't selling
any tickets that's what they let him go
yeah but that was that weight class but
who in that weight class sells tickets
so then he was he wasn't a big one
so they so it doesn't hurt their bottom
line to let him go
right right same thing with Goldberg man
like you like Goldberg oh it seems like
a big deal but you know Rogan was doing
a lot of work I thought Goldberg was
great I don't like the way they do
business
hey so yeah I kind of agree with that I
agree with that I think they they're
they're I think I'd trust a lot of their
employees are disgruntled and I'm in
particular fighters but you heard
[ __ ] refs [ __ ] about it you've heard
the ring girls [ __ ] about it and you've
heard a lot of people and that other
ring girls bitching of understand you
hear them [ __ ] why are we getting paid
I walk around I let people know it's
like what is your service how is that
still a thing by the way other than me -
yeah we're in girls at a Howard Shirley
is we don't need you I mean it's like we
don't I mean like I can look up Oh what
round is it
I don't need tits McGee over here
telling me what round it is well they're
not there for to tell you really what
are they there to give me boners yeah
yeah of course yeah I know we give them
a task so it seems important but the
point is that crying about not getting
paid and
he's ridiculous I want it I do wonder
where they get paid a ring girl oh yeah
so how long has she been hot by the way
yeah I was gonna say she's like the main
obvious issues about she must have liked
some [ __ ] preachers of like Dana
White just slopping black knob it's like
if I get caught my pictures go live that
really is the easiest wheel of fortune
have you ever notice they never get
close no not anymore no you really do he
really has become an Angeline you know
he's got fans in front of her face now
on stunt doubles and [ __ ] I'm the NBA on
TNT when wasn't the white guy what's his
name Ernie Johnson Ernie Johnson has
disease they never did close and I
thought was really respectful that they
kept him on I think that's very cool
he's a good guy dude that's a bad the
best casting forever they shot drew
brees from one side cuz he had that
chocolate [ __ ] Hershey bar on the side
of his face and he got it it doesn't
look much better now he got it off you
know it's just this giant cavity I mean
what's so we're not gonna [ __ ] you or
what I mean what's the point of this
yeah if people call him [ __ ] saying who
cares own it own it own it what just mr.
stain my bank account [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah I mean I don't know hey you when
you get the money they just be like you
know what I've always wanted a third I
[ __ ] throw a [ __ ] third eye on me
get it out in your forehead I've seen
that yeah I've seen that mug shots sure
yeah that's what you should do is get a
Reeve Superman eye but always just keep
a bandaid on it and then people like
what is it just be like look around and
then just show some real quick and cover
back up and be like I have to keep a
bandaid on it cuz it makes me dizzy guy
came to my show no face from of you what
he didn't have a face what do you mean
remember that guide to comedy Stone no
thank you
I don't know I we didn't ask him I mean
I guess hey how'd that happen do you do
that was guys nobody hell if you know
praises you can tell I know what
happened in Oh face not making a joke at
all about tell you a funny joke to Berra
said so no face was this guy that used
to come around and start and his face
was all just
no face and no thanks guys walking
around like somebody from Mortal Kombat
he had like the [ __ ] Sub Zero mascot
doesn't bracelet no face he was gotten
to a boating accident and his face got
hit with the [ __ ] propeller oh [ __ ]
oh that's happenin no face so then one
time I would just walk around with a
Lucha Libre mask on or even just like a
[ __ ] Windows like plastic ones were
you like a Ronald Reagan everybody
should Libre depending on how you feel
they'll know by what mask you're wearing
oh yeah right but anyway so no fit this
is again no joke bout tell you dombarris
is joke which is so funny no face
actually makes out with a girl to calm
sure some [ __ ] crazy girl all of it
saw it he's got like a weird like I'm
like I'm his mouth is on Mongol DUP was
she part of the ding dong so I don't
know maybe I don't know but it was a
weird girl she's making out with no face
so then I'm talking to Don Barris the
next night I go gee [ __ ] no face
hooked up with a girl last night he's
like yeah I heard pal here's the problem
he's gonna tell all there's no face
friends at the store no there's gonna be
a bunch of no faces hanging out we
already just heard too cuz I know one
intelligence the one that came to your
show and then the ogee one at the store
did your no faces have hair because the
guy I'm thinking of doesn't have hair
yeah there's no face the store no affair
just like Mortal Kombat my nose face is
a fire victim and he had no hair you
have a third dog face yeah I knew one in
childhood yeah you know if you see one
it's good luck no years he had no ears
his ears that right yeah really yeah
yeah this is no face had a year we just
had no face they could see there the
head eyes you need had a friend there
who's basically translating for ya no
face I always tell he just made a lot of
beeping noises he [ __ ] at least got
his dick sucked by [ __ ] no mouth oh
she had no mouth I should have mentioned
that now she had a mouth it was all over
his no face I saw her mouth on his no
face well now did somebody put her up
where she may
cow with just a hole that was kind of
licking around them our I guess that's
somebody who [ __ ] like probably
fingerblast herself the faces of death
right yeah that's a fetish kind of thing
and for sure you'd blow one now is the
first person beggars can't be choosers
person a hug a guy in a wheelchair is a
hot chick they just have to hug them
they just walk up and hug them hi how
are you they're like over happy to see
them well everyone's like oh great
wheelchair guys here yeah yeah yeah I
mean we hope you ever hear Brian
Holtzman's joke about the wheelchair guy
at the wedding no but I can't wait
funny dude what is why are you there huh
huh you're getting the picture you're
depressing everybody you gotta be in the
picture don't you know when you go to
[ __ ] porn convention it's all
wheelchair people oh of course it's all
weird - yeah that Mexicans in wheelchair
that's their comic-con yeah keep me in
the nobody show you there's a guy who
knows everything about tree frogs they
respect him nobody has any [ __ ]
respect
and my vast knowledge of pornography
okay somebody knows everything about no
faces Larry
yeah Larry Flynt is still alive he's
still lie I would take him in it I would
take him in a death pool hey when are we
doing this bat which bet but are the
trans whoa I'm not here next week by the
way okay so when when is you do it next
week or two whenever no get out let's
say like the winds website coming out I
say we do not announce Tuesday the
following Tuesday we said what is that
day look it up put it in wait you're
still alive how old is he
76 yeah but he's a bad 76 he's a no-face
7 you say the 9th of April are you the
following that's fifth marriage the 16th
of April is the following yeah do you
want to do that Monday night before so
we had can have it for the show when we
come in the next day to talk about no
we'll do it that we'll talk about in the
next one
I mean it'll be a week later if we talk
about fine whatever you talk about on
the patreon - yeah I mean we do all
sorts imagine yeah I'm busy mom is the
best
Tuesday's easier than Monday off from my
shows we'll have it will bang out
everything and then he can call hey can
you call it a masturbate on Tuesday no
I'm shooting something okay all right I
could get fired doing that
I'll pull excite sumac so so I'm doing
with those talking heads that you all
did jerk off you know what else the
trans walk and there's one more oh I got
to get electrocuted for two straight
hours and then go to the hospital after
that no I just get my balls tasered for
why is your flesh like always on oh so
are we good so that it's set in stone
you know I wouldn't say that no it's in
my phone it's set in stone set in phone
that is good stone that's [ __ ] hot in
here guys pleasure
this has been great this is punch-drunk
no sports we're winners win all that no
great we see you guys soon